[Music]
on the first full day of a court ruling
that limits noise from truck horns the
occupation at the foot of parliament
hill is quieter but after allowing the
protesters to become embedded here
ottawa city police insist they are
determined to get rid of them there is
absolutely a need to end this we are
actively working to do it through
peaceful
progressive negotiations but we also
have looked at enforcement angles to
move ascend but how soon
to follow through city police say they
need an additional 1800 officers and
civilian personnel from other police
agencies it's unclear how many have been
procured the federal government through
the rcmp has been proactive in providing
a tangible concrete support by assigning
275 rcmp officers who are now working
closely with
the ops the opp to enforce community
safety ottawa police say they've made 22
arrests
issued more than 1300 tickets
and there are dozens of ongoing criminal
investigations including one following
the alleged attack of an officer if and
when the time comes to remove these
vehicles it's unclear who will do the
moving
every company on the city of ottawa's go
to list of tow truck drivers has
rejected requests to move heavy vehicles
from downtown they rely on heavy truck
industry for their livelihood and they
don't want to damage that part of their
business polling shows a clear majority
of canadians oppose the occupation but
protesters say they've received enormous
support from people driving to ottawa
mostly from other parts of ontario if
you think that this is just a fringe
movement and there's only a small
percentage of canadians think there's
something nefarious going on with their
government and in our country then
you're dreaming for police there are
numerous considerations they say almost
a quarter of the 418 trucks encamped in
the city have children living in them
complicating any discussion of how to
proceed with a possible operation we're
not at the stage of looking
to do any sort of
enforcement activity around that we'll
rely on the children's aid society to
help provide and give us guidance around
that still more questions than answers
as the occupation continues ross lord
global news ottawa